just pull over just drop me on the side
of the tree I won't say anything I won't
say anything
[Applause]
[Music]
no love you both of
you
Jes who's
this it's me somebody's killing us
someone's
[Music]
coming Joe what are you not telling
me long before we
met I did bad
things we're in
danger the kids I'm going to fix
this why did you contact me to warn you
need to find Diana and you trust her
we're going to be dealing with some very
serious people this is going to be
fun doesn't matter what you
do what you
[Music]
say you can't out run
us if we fight we die if we run we
die most things in this world way more
scared of you than you are of them
because we're apex
predators coffee I'd like a coffee do
you want a
[Music]
coffee